[Music]
foreign
posters and pictures
part of a family planning display at a
rural fair in India
but here another attraction
a group of folk dancers
artists performers
arrival attraction
or is it
[Music]
a traditional folk media are close to
and of the people
they invite audience participation
traditional media liked the song The
Dance the drama of India existed long
before modern mass media
or as they've been there to entertain
educate interpret and reinforce existing
ideas and ideologies
can such deeply rooted and traditional
media themselves be used for change
the change of fundamentally held
attitudes which is required by the
concept of family planning
before printing
before reading
long before radio or television
oral communication
speech
talk gossip
ate
[Music]
in rural India folk poetry is still a
living thing
a direct telling of tales and pointing
of morals to an audience directly
involved
traveling storytellers
they can be convinced of the event for
small families and they in turn can
incorporate this message in their
traditional Tales
[Music]
not a platform for poets this time but
puppets
a little theater easily made transported
assembled wherever an audience is found
animated puppets still appeal and
attract and with them it is possible to
achieve a degree of audience
participation impossible with purely
mechanical media
the Puppeteer can adapt what he says and
how he says it according to the mood and
nature of a particular audience
an audience will accept instruction
criticism even from a puppet figure
which might be resented from a live
performer let alone an official
beard you and his wife were happy
in their little home
soon even happier with two children of
Their Own
[Music]
heart but all too soon came more and
more and more children
and with them
trouble Strife
[Music]
[Applause]
all beer juice money went
their clothes became rags
his poor wife was at her wit's end
there seemed no answer to his troubles
in this world
yeah
but wait quick
enter the field worker the family
planner
yes
you need not have brought all this
misery on yourself
come talk to the doctor
he will explain
you need not have had all those children
you can live a happy prosperous life
like you did when you had just two
children
Family Planning
[Music]
out there in the country is your
audience
out there with them are the roots and
origins of traditional folk media
very old and increasingly fragile
folk media can be used in Urgent
information programs like Family
Planning communication
but you should be careful not to
overload them with your message risking
as a result their destruction altogether
however popular the visit to a village
of a traveling group may be
it is no good giving performers a script
and telling them what to do
they themselves must first of all be
made aware of understand and appreciate
what you are asking of them
you should leave the method just how the
new theme is to be developed in the
hands of the artist the performer
or scenario if you like but let the
performers the artists devise their own
method and format
study the forms of the folk media in a
particular region and then decide how
they can best be modified and used
[Music]
[Applause]
but be certain the artist performer
understands and believes in this
adaptation
[Music]
then let him work it out in his own way
let him talk to the audience during and
after the show
[Music]
talati didn't want to know that field
worker with the family planning leaflet
he was all right the way he was with his
wife even though she wanted to learn all
about it
but then dalati had a terrible dream
[Music]
he was called to judgmental
not for him the reward of beautiful
dancing girls at the court of the Raja
banishment
ignominy
impoverishment
death
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it was after all only a dream
with the family planner and his wife a
much relieved to Lati gets the message
and they make sure the audience now gets
it too
in song
[Music]
and singing are as much of the folk and
folk media as poetry drama dance
folk songs can be adapted in folk songs
words are more important than the actual
Melody which is simple well-known and
repetitive
this means that you can graft fresh
words and new thought and motivation
onto old and accepted Tunes
[Music]
a small house a little garden
perched in a tree in the garden a bird
is singing
the trees bear fruit in season but only
then
but man he never ceases
the goddess Earth pleads daily that she
is already overburdened
oh man can you not change your ways
[Music]
something real to sing about
I'm gonna
[Music]
wow
but behind it hard work
I'm beautiful
work which must begin with the creation
of a family planning communication unit
dealing with every aspect of
communication and its coordination with
field work among its tasks can be the
drawing up of an inventory of folk media
then a decision as to how best they can
be used
foreign
[Music]
the extension arm of the mass media you
might say is folk media
folk media can be the most effective of
all the Styles and forms recorded and
transmitted by the mass media
[Music]
programs should be more than just
straightforward recordings of seemingly
dying art forms
what is needed is reinterpretation of
folk media in the light of today's
urgent issues
here is a new and fresh dimension in a
people's traditional art and culture
[Music]
[Applause]
you can understand how that magical
talking and moving picture comes to
appear on that screen
fuel can identify with feel at home with
the city scene the foreign film
[Music]
everyone can respond to its programs if
they are a reflection of and rooted in
the same Traditions that people have
known instinctively over the ages
[Music]
midnight
[Applause]
[Music]
the folk artist being of the people can
reinforce his message from his platform
face to face with people in his own
community
[Music]
foreign
with the extension worker
the field worker must be out there in
the audience too
to take advantage of shifts of attitude
and the climate of acceptance created by
the performance
[Music]
many people have come to the clinic
through the use of folk media
with careful adaptation and the help of
extension workers out there in the field
there can be many more
[Music]
thank you foreign